So animals can consent to with humans, but merely being able
to consent isn't enough. The animal would need to be able to
give informed consent, which they can't. And so therefore, Adam
finds
>> An animal has its maximal capacity to consent and it
is enjoying it. Like it's obviously consenting. Um, it is not
at the level of human consent, but for the animal, it will never
have a higher level of consent. So you're not like harming the
animal is like the argument he's making. >> How many of
you are under 13? >> Oh no.
Dude, look at that. Look how old he is. >> He's like 12.
What she just referenced, guys. There's a Nandros video. Nandros
ever the digger. Okay.
He's decided to put his finger on the scale in favor of the round
one. Okay. Okay, he's coming in to save Nicholas and Rob's media.
He's decided to drop his own video calling out YMS. Okay, and
that's the title is your movie sucks. Has been
for 10 years. Oh, Nikandros apparently in another chat was talking
about how he is going to he gave Rob this stuff. Now, Neandros
is just anti- degeneracy. Okay, that's his position, right? These
degenerate losers who are exposing kids to sh. All right. I don't
think he really defends Rob's media. I think he more just goes,
"You know what? Adam ain't got no right to speak on this." If
you know, guys, this ties into the YMS versus Rob's media. If
you watch the YMS hit pieces from before, uh, this is
Yms versus Nicholas Yorio Rob's Media. They're trying to count,
they're like kind of doing a hit piece on him or they're kind
of like mocking him for his furess.
Okay, he is a furry openly. Yms, of course, if you're unaware.
Yms, one of the biggest one of the biggest movie reviewers on
YouTube. Okay. Massive movie reviewer. Kima the White Lion. Okay.
Yms 1.1 million views. Possibly YouTube's biggest furry. All
right. Possibly the biggest furry on YouTube. I haven't checked.
I don't know for sure, but quite possibly the largest. My position
from before was basically we don't really have proof of Adam
causing harm. But the thing that with me when he was doing these
arguments, okay, Adam would play devil's advocate and he'd say
he doesn't really care, but he would always make the act utilitarian
argument of, well, technically a human and a dog could have a
relationship and that could be beneficial to both of them, okay?
Not not causing harm to either. And it's like, yeah, I don't
think so, man. Like, I understand what you're saying, but I think
that's an argument that as a rule doesn't work. And I think it's
probably like weird to make it and to, you know, it's just weird
weird stuff. So, this is uh this is a response. This is him making
some of these arguments in other places and a little bit of critique.
>> Welcome. I'm Nantro. If you're wondering where that
big video is that I've been hyping up, I'll talk about that later.
Rob's Media released a video recently showing a bunch of instances
where your movie sucks. Yms or Adam has criticized laws criminalizing.
According to Adam, people shouldn't go to jail for engaging in
what he calls non-abusive
contact with animals. And he reiterated the stance in his response
to Rob's video. >> In my position, just another parallel
to that I want a toaster meme. It is the I want a toaster meme.
And Adam makes some of those arguments. Okay. Yes, it is exactly
that >> with animals. And he reiterated the stance in his
response to Rob's video. And my position has always been that
even though I would like it not to happen, even though I don't
like that thing, you know, I have no interest in it and I would
prefer if other people don't do it. If you give me a world, you
know, where no people are doing that versus a world where people
are doing that. I would choose the world where no
>> uh yes, soapbox society, that is the yes are doing that.
Right. That's always been my position. However, I do love it.
We love the >> many of our legal policies regarding this
issue are not based on the welfare of the animal. >> He
brings up how humans regularly makes contact with animals not
for pleasure but for the purpose of breeding them as part of
animal husbandry or agriculture. >> If somebody is doing
it but has a different thought in their head. If that's not their
thought, but their thought is instead, oh, this is hot or whatever,
people believe that person should be in jail, which if you believe
that, that's fine. But just admit,
to be fair, I think most people would think that's just like
a that's like a win-win. If your job was you're like somebody
who who does uh like artificial insemination for horses and that
gets you off at the same time, I think a lot of people would
be like, "Well, the job's got to be done." Or cows or something.
Well, job's got to be done, I guess. I don't think people would
want you necessarily jailed for that if you're just doing the
exact things they were doing. It's like, but it's it's the problem
is most people don't think you'll stop there, right? Most people
don't think that's going to be where you stop. Most people don't
trust it. It's
h maybe not most people. I'm thinking like maybe from my point
of view or something, but yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I just No. King of
town. I just thought of that and then I was like, "Wait, wait,
wait, hold on, hold on,
wait." Hey, but that king of town that does apply to what I'm
saying as well is you just aren't certain that they'll stop or
that they can draw the line effectively
because people's inhibitions, you know, people's decision-m is
like significantly altered when they're in some situation, right?
You just don't believe they'll put the welfare of the animal
first that you you want them to be in jail for a thought crime,
right? You want them to be in jail because of what was happening
in their brain, not because of the welfare of the animal, right?
If it was because of the welfare of the animal, then you would
also believe that other people should be in jail for doing the
same thing. Again, not even considering the meat industry. Not
even considering >> So, his stance has always been that
he's against and but didn't he say that animals can consent to
with humans? >> People have asked me, how is it possible
for an animal to consent to a human being? And my answer was
the same way it consents to another animal. Now people have interpreted
that as me saying animals want to have sex with human beings
and therefore it's all good or whatever. People have interpreted
that as me saying all act. So this is not really great because
an animal of course has diminished capacity consent. There are
other things that have diminished capacity consent in our lives
and we would never say that like well if they want to have sex
with you then it's fine, right? We would never say that. like
the the actual informed consent element is probably something
most humans think should be there outside of other elements that
feed into like human thriving like the agriculture arguments
right with regards to force breeding and stuff actions you know
towards animals are permissible because of that that is not my
position things that are a part of our common knowledge in pop
culture like America's funniest home videos right there will
be a clip of like ah women fell down a And then the dog just
starts humping her. And so my response is, is the dog not consenting
to some sort of act by doing a on the human? Right. Sure, it's
not informed consent, right? And that doesn't mean, oh, dogs
humping you, therefore you can do something else to it. I never
said that. It's not informed consent. It's not my standard for
consent, but it seems possible, right? It seems seems like they
have their own version. It seems seems like they have their
So animals can consent to sex. >> Never said that. That's
not informed consent. It's not my standard for consent, but it
seems possible, right? It seem seems like they have their own
>> So animals can consent to with humans, but merely being
able to consent isn't enough. The animal would need to be able
to give informed consent, which they can't. And so therefore,
Adam finds immoral. But he questions why artificial insemination,
etc. is illegal. But that doesn't harm the animal is criminal.
There's many angles from which you can criticize Adam's deep
philosophical thinking here. In the case of Rob's media, he compared
Adam to Vosch since Vosch liked to debate the ethics of before
it was revealed that he had lolly on his computer and more recently
it came out that he had tried to groom a minor in 2017. So Rob
is suspecting that Adam is secretly a zoo file or behind the
scenes. But Adam claims that's not the case at all. He's never
held that position. So is Adam like Vosch? Is he a zoo file or
a supporter? He says he isn't. But I think Adam is in denial.
I think he's suffering from repressed memories. I found this
old video which I >> [__] Uh-oh.
Repressed memories. Uhoh. >> It's interesting. Let's check
it out.
>> Oh god. Nickandro seems to have engineered another another
what what is the site called? Another like YouTube transcript
search query. Okay. He's engineered yet another one to go and
catch Adam at some point in the far past doing some that most
people are not going to appreciate. Okay.
Well, let's check it out. Let's see. Let's see where it goes.
I'm not a support of
I'm a support of
of uh consensual
supporter of uh consensual.
I don't encourage it. I'm not going to convince someone to try
it. I've never tried it. I don't intend on never trying it, but
I recognize that people exist that will live their whole lives.
I support Wait, what does he support? uh consensual zu
consensual
supporter of uh consensual zuilia.
He's a supporter of
zuilia because it moved on to some wild listen even less. We
disavow. Yeah, I' I've said repeatedly that I don't think this
argument holds up at all. I don't think it's a good argument
for him to make and he refuses to back down from it. Uh from
what I've seen, I think it's a weird argument to make. I don't
think it's a good argument to make. Seems kind of harmful. I
feel like you only make this argument if you are personally invested.
That's how I feel about it.
That's as close as I can come to saying basically accusing him
of something. So, I'm I don't want to accuse him him of something,
but he seems like personally invested in a way that doesn't track
with he should be able to understand the that he's like straying
into actual like Bosch argumentation territory there. And I don't
know why he doesn't. >> I don't encourage it. I'm not going
to convince someone to try it. I've never tried it. I don't intend
on never trying it. But I recognize that people exist that will
live their whole lives with an urge to do something like that.
And meanwhile, while every other person on the planet gets to
fulfill their eternal, psychological,
emotionally/physically
driven ur urges, these other people on the planet that are attracted
to the wrong thing somehow aren't able to do that despite not
harming animals in any way that they wouldn't be harmed through
any other
activity. You know, >> this is the this is like the quintessential
example of the guy the fat guy at the whiteboard who's explaining,
you know, that sped up clip. That's what he's doing right now.
He's like doing the you guys all know what I'm talking about,
right? Fat guy beard, whiteboard marker. >> 10 years ago,
he identified himself as a supporter and he portrayed zoo files
as victims of societal injustice. I'm going to give him some
mercy. This video is from 10 years ago, but no matter what, he's
lied to his audience. He either lied about never having supported
or he's lying right now and he actually does still support it,
but he simply learned to hide his true beliefs. What about his
stance on animals capacity for >> to suggest that there's
no such thing as consensual human/an animal is to be the most
naive person on the planet. Dogs try to hump your leg. That's
all the evidence I need. I don't have to have sex with an animal
to know that animal again, nobody is arguing
that people with diminished capacity or without agency, nobody's
arguing that you can like that that they could try to do something
like that. Nobody's arguing against that, right? Like you just
have to understand that a child could do the same thing to you,
right? A child could do the same thing to you. a like I guess
I'm trying to think he would there would be arguments against
that but like it dude
cuz that's like the animal's height of consent that they'll ever
reach. There's an argument with a child that like they have memories.
There would be something further on but yeah like a like a actual
person with Down syndrome or something could do that to you.
You could make the same argument. They'd never have more capacity
to consent later. Is that like fine because of that? animal don't
have the same type of reservations that human beings do when
it comes to if it feels good, they're probably okay with it.
If they try to bite you or run away, that's probably a sign that
they're not okay with it. So, the argument that oh, you can't
tell if it's consenting or not, even though it's clearly enjoying
itself. Okay. Such I can't believe people I can't hold on. Can't
believe >> I There's more coming. How much of society is
just dictated by people saying I don't like it or that's gross
or they're not a part of my tribe. It's disgusting to me. It's
disgusting to me. Human animals is not nearly as disgusting as
the mentality that discriminates against people who have never
abused animals that are attracted to animals. I'd like to point
out that this is
>> ah
like your bigotry actually offends me more than somebody sucking
a dog's is just a weird thing to say. I get that he doesn't make
it anymore. This is what he was probably talking. He's like I
used to talk about this stuff but before I realized how bigoted
people were. It's like yeah man these are not good clips to have
out there though. Jesus. >> This is not a live stream VOD.
It is a highlight. He thought he was really spitting here. >> I'm
sure that's crazy, right? that it's like it's literally not >> it's
not his VOD. It's like he cut up his VOD and this was the stuff
he included when he cut up his VOD. >> It is a highlight.
He thought he was really spitting here. >> I'm sure if
somebody was having sex with an animal and they were enjoying
it and they got caught, I'm sure they would be able to prove
that the animals enjoying it in court if they're allowed to just
Wait, but listen to listen to his argument for why. Listen to
his argument for why. Hold on. >> Really spitting here.
>> I'm sure if somebody was having sex with an animal and
they were enjoying it and they got caught, I'm sure they would
be able to prove that the animal was enjoying it in court.
>> Now listen to how how do you guys think they would prove
it? Cuz
if they're allowed to just do it and record it again or something,
I'm sure they'd be able to prove it if that's what they're doing.
If somebody Wow.
If they just Listen, your honor,
I call to the stand
Benji,
my Yorkshire terrier. Okay, I call him to the stand and we're
going to demonstrate just how non-abusive this is. See, with
your with your bigoted eyes, see if you can deny our love. See
if you could deny it's real. Okay. Yeah, sure. Sure. Yeah. Uh
it's it's brutal. We just went through the part where he said
like, "Well, if you could prove it in court by having with the
dog again and showing and showing that the dog is not affected
adversely.
It's just uh
>> but he's abusing an animal. >> He would he would
be on the stand. He would be like, "Your honor, I have no scratches.
Clearly, he enjoyed it. >> Clearly, he enjoyed it. Animal
and having sex with it. I am not in favor of that. But I'm just
not naive enough to believe that there's no such thing as an
as an animal that can enjoy having with a human being. They're
just horny animals. They don't give a [__] They don't
they don't have and then go, "Oh, I wonder I wonder what he thought
about me or am I really with the right person or is this what
I want to do with my life?" Or any of the other human psychologically
repressed uh uh reservations that we have. Animals don't do that.
They don't think that far. They just want to ejaculate. that's
all they want to do. >> So, in the past, he believed that
a human standard of consent doesn't apply to animals. Not just
that, but he claims there's no evidence that consensual human
animal interactions are psychologically harmful to the animal.
If we gave a about animals being psychologically affected, even
though a there's no evidence to suggest that they would be negatively
psychologically affected by consensual enjoyable,
even if there were, you don't put people in jail for leaving
a dog in a kennel when it doesn't want to be in a kennel. You
don't put people in jail for feeding an animal that Listen, you
don't even I mean, technically technically he's getting pretty
close to like animal abuse. Not actually. He's like basically
saying people who are like their animals, but he's getting pretty
close. Like there's a line there where we do want to take the
dog away from the person, right? The same food over and >> I
guess. Sorry. I guess his argument is you take the dog away,
you don't go to jail. Okay. >> Again, it's entire life.
You don't put people in jail for leaving a dog in in your back
porch with nowhere to go to the bathroom.
>> Yes. Really talking. He is basically arguing that an
animal has its maximal capacity to consent and it is enjoying
it. like it's obviously consenting. Um it is not the level of
human consent, but for the animal, it will never have a higher
level of consent. So, you're not like harming the animal is like
the argument he's making. Um I think you're probably harming
yourself by taking like there's something to be said for like
you are taking advantage of something that doesn't have your
capacity for consent. There's like something harmful there inherently
that you can't be sure that um one, you can't even be sure the
the dog could complain. two, you can't even be sure that the
oh, what was it? You can't even be sure
that the person wouldn't apply like a lot of these same arguments
to equal situations. Like there's just it feels like there's
there's some kind of there's like some downstream consequences
to believing this is okay.
It's it's bizarre to me. Okay. Leave it there for like 8 hours
while you're gone to work. come back and once you see that it
itself because it had nowhere to go, then you rub their nose
in their
you don't put people in. No, no, no, no, no, no. Kuryoko
and there there's more to his argument than that. He's not saying
he's not saying enjoyment overrides informed consent. He's saying
that they their capacity to consent. Like if they're doing something
like he did the humping your leg thing and they're enjoying it
and they're having a good time and they're doing a thing they
want to do, that's like okay. He's saying even you can't escalate
beyond that. Like it's his argument is basically I understand
his argument. It's I still feel like I reject even this argument
>> in jail for that. So you shouldn't put people in jail
for sucking a dog's dick. Seriously, the world is up. The world
is so up. We eat and >> Oh, there's no way he hits that
sound clip, too.
>> Oh, it's brutal. >> Did you hear it? >> Go
to >> once you see that it hit itself because it had nowhere
to go.
Dude, there are so many like terrible things going on in the
world and he's sitting here like the world's soed up because
of because people don't get to suck a dog's. >> To be fair,
it's 10 years ago. So, the world was a little better. It was
like right before Trump got elected. The world was pretty
>> Maybe this was the most pressing thing in his life at
that point.
>> He's making, you know, hundreds of thousands of dollars
off of YouTube. He's
this is rich people problems. They won't let me this dog. >> This
might have been his biggest issue. Yeah. Well, >> yeah.
Might have been his biggest issue. Who knows? >> Too busy
watching movies, not watching anything actually going on in the
world.
>> Yeah, I guess so. Or then you rub their nose in their
You don't put people in jail for that. So, you shouldn't put
people in jail for sucking a dog's dick. Seriously, the world
is [__] up. The world is soed up. We you going to
you you wouldn't put somebody in jail for feeding a dog the same
food every day. Imagine the torture of eating the same food every
day. You wouldn't put somebody in jail for that doing that to
an animal. So why would you put them in jail for sucking a dog's
eat
up? >> Uhhuh. We are discriminating against people and
the only reason that people hold a different standard to it is
because they're attracted to something that other people aren't.
And that is what is absolutely disgusting about
I'm passionate about it because it's
>> Huge huge discrimination going on right >> Are
you sure there's nothing else behind this passion? >> I
I stand by these statements. I don't If I'm If I'm crucified
for these statements, then 20 years from now, people will look
back at this and be like, "Wow,
I can't believe all these people were that stupid to crucify
him for those statements." >> He literally believes that
will be normalized in 10 years. And Okay. 20 years. 20 years.
All right. 20 20 years. Not 10 years. 20 years. All right. We
should be very clear on that cuz otherwise you could just say
he was
>> You never know. The next listen, the next like 10 years
we might go in a really crazy direction. All right. Yeah. I don't
think so. But >> And it's also it's also to say he knew
he was going to upset like the entire internet with this. >> He
did. He did. Yeah. >> He's all for it. Also, I would say
I don't think he's that young here. Hold on. Hold on. What's
his age?
Oh, no. He is young. Okay. Okay. He was 24 here. I thought he
was like 40 now. Somebody told me he was like 40 now. He's 34.
>> He was 24. Okay. So, >> he's 24. >> He's
24. Nick Fuentes around this time is like building up his movement
and Adam is building up his
>> uh
movement. Not successfully, but yeah, you know, 24 year olds
can be dangerous.
>> Yes, they can. Listen, have you ever heard Trump talk
about how beautiful dogs are, we might be closer than you think.
Okay. I believe that by making these statements that I am on
the right side of history is all I'm saying. >> He's on
the right side of history. So, Adam claims he's always held certain
positions, but now it turns out that that was false. Not only
was he far more supportive of in the past, he explicitly identified
himself as a supporter, he also claims he's >> consensual
supporter. Consensual >> gone on these rants multiple other
>> I'll say this again. I went on this same rant in like
20 other videos. >> He seems to have some heavy personal
investment in the subject. It doesn't seem like a random thought
experiment. If you look up the full highlight, his arguments
and examples are very similar to the ones he brings up now. He's
clearly lied and omitted that he supported Sufilia in the past.
So, his credibility isn't looking too hot. But it only gets worse.
In his response to Rob's video, he decided to accuse him of sending
nudes to minors and for grooming
>> Okay, I think Hold on.
>> Where's Where's the grooming? So, I remember asking
you guys, where's the grooming allegation? I think Nandros found
it. I think he did say something. It's like akin to grooming.
>> Yo, he decided to accuse him of sending >> that
Rob's media. >> Yeah, Rob's media was doing something akin
to grooming. So, we couldn't find it. I I asked people. We looked
for it. Yeah, it seems like it's from the >> nudes to miners
and for grooming children. He repeated the claim on Twitter and
then retweeted an implication that Rob is a >> sharing
me. Oh, am I sharing the wrong window? Hold on, hold on, hold
on. Holding on. There we go.
He repeated the claim on Twitter.
>> So absolutely crazy that these two idiots thought sharing
with minors was perfectly fine until getting called out on Twitter.
Now I think this is like an okay stance to have, but you'd probably
need to I think Nicandra does some good counter-arguments to
it here. This is like a this is like an okay stance to have like
oh you should be very careful with how you're describing content
if you have unaggered
>> and then retweeted an implication that Rob is a what's
the basis for these claims? Rob showed the name of Adam's NSFW
Twitter account and described some post from it. Adam claims
he is worried about kids being funneled to the account through
Rob's video. So why didn't he set that account to protect it?
It's his account. If he genuinely believed that masses of miners
were flowing to it, shouldn't he have done that? Adam clearly
doesn't believe that this is a real issue. It's a total distraction.
He did a bit in one of his videos. >> I would say that
is probably a good argument. I would I think >> that this
is concern trolling. Well, that like if you were really that
concerned and you were really that worried about the
of kids, even though it's them forcing it on you, even though
they're the party doing the wrong like engaging in the wrongdoing,
you would try to minimize the harm to children if that was your
primary concern, right? >> Signal boost it on your main
Twitter account and platform. >> Yeah. Versus versus Yeah.
As opposed to you're going to signal boost it, you're going to
argue about with them and you're going to use kids as a cudel
to do it, right? I do think that's a good argument. I don't think
that is
everything. I don't think that's like um
it's a good argument in that I think it's weird that Adam leads
with this. It's his like strongest argument against them. It's
what he knows he can use in like the public in the public sphere,
but like do you really believe this? Is this really like where
your heart is? Is this your really your biggest concern? Probably
not if you never even private the account, right?
>> Yeah. videos where he shows himself going to a fairy
website and then describes some of the posts.
I should look some up right now. >> Oh, look. He's at a
YouTube studio blur. Covering up that one letter will really
do wonders. He's telling kids about a website full of thousands
and thousands of videos and images. And he's showing himself
going on it like it's all normal. It's a casual normal thing
to >> I didn't describe any of the these images beyond
saying, "Oh, a demigorgan's in one. Haha, that's funny." I didn't
say what acts are taking place in the images. I didn't say who
was penetrating who. And also, it's not in the context of let's
shame this person, right?
It's not in that context. It's in the context of haha, this movie
is so boring that I'm going to look up.
So, we pointed that out during during this. It's like, bro, I
don't think it matters the context. Like, you can't say, oh,
just because they're shaming me for this like behavior that it's
bad. But when I'm doing it as a joke, it's like no, they're like
arguably there's no way you can go uh what is this? This is sort
of like the um it's just like it's it's just a weird argument
to make. I didn't I was just, you know, being absent- minded
and exposing kids. They were trying to draw attention to like
something they think is morally wrong. They're like doing a public
announcement. They they're arguing they're they're making a video
in the public interest. Like they think they're the good guys.
They have some idea. You just did it willy-nilly for no reason.
you were just [__] around. >> Well, the thing
is if you have the concern, right, and if you think the other
person is more malicious than you and you did not have ill intention,
you should be able to acknowledge your harm because you're concerned
as children. They've pointed out a harm that you did. You're
like, "Oh, I didn't do that intentionally." You should be able
to own up to it. You don't if you have that genuine concern for
the safety of children or you want them to be exposed to this,
you won't sweep what you did and be like, "That's not a big deal.
That's like me shoring." These guys are the child groomers.
>> You won't do that. You'll have some ability to introspect
and self-reflect on what you've done and be like, "Yeah, that
was bad. I shouldn't have done >> But what he did was make
excuses for >> He made excuses for himself. And the excuses
don't really make sense to me. >> They don't make sense.
And then the allegation against them doesn't make
>> Well, the allegation against them makes sense in that
I think everybody does this, right? They minimize their wrongdoing.
They're like, "Oh, I didn't mean to." Right? And they're like,
"Well, I didn't mean to." And you know, my thing was like slightly
less bad and you're the one who made a video about it in the
first place. Like they're both doing this hypocrisy thing against
each >> You said he did say grooming kids, right? That's
what I'm saying. >> I think he says it with his voice at
some point here. >> I can't remember if I missed it. I'm
pretty sure he says it with his voice at some point here.
>> No, that literally makes it worse. Rob is telling the
kids in his audience. >> You're right though, that if he
calls it grooming, then he's engaged in the same behavior. That
makes it weird to use that label, right? E either it's a forgivable
thing that you've like done this without really meaning to. Or
it's >> and you should probably now concern trolling and
you're using this as a way to attack them, >> which is
probably what both sides are doing. Both sides are really concern
trolling. Yes. >> People who go on these websites and enjoy
this material are disgusting degenerates and they should be ashamed.
If Rob has impressionable children in his audience who take what
he says seriously, do you think they're more or less likely to
visit those sites? How do you think the impressionable children
in >> I also think this is a hor I think this is probably
a bad argument too that like he's Dude, it gets so weird when
you're calling out like somebody's um hypocrisy cuz like I don't
necessarily think this is a good argument. Well, if they're impressionable,
Rob's criticizing it. So, if they're impressionable and they
take Rob's word seriously, they wouldn't go to that website.
No, man. Even if you respect somebody's opinion and they say,
"Don't go here."
Right? People, young people being told, "Don't do this." That's
a big red flag. You know, they're a m you're a matador. You got
the big red cape. >> Just young people. There are older
vulnerably vulnerable people. If you just sane people, if you
tell me don't do something, I'm thinking about how much why can't
I hiding? What are you hiding from? going to do that. >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> Yeah. I'm >> audience respond to you showing
looking up as a casual thing to do when you're bored. You review
and talk about kids movies. There's no way you have zero kids
in your audience. Also, you have absolutely no
business having this tone given your history. >> Don't
post that [__] in chat. Don't Don't post links. >> I'm
pretty I'm pretty sure certain states have laws against that.
So, I don't I don't want I don't I don't want uh any of that
porn in this chat. animated. That's okay. >> But I I would
ask that mods would regulate to make sure. I didn't even click
on the link. >> Dude, how do you go animated is okay? >> Why
Why is anybody linking in your chat? >> Well, also
that sort of
that's it's sort of weird in that somebody It sounds like somebody
literally posted a video of like a a dog somebody or somebody
sucking off a dog in his chat, right? Like that's unquestionably
he actually rules out any other possibility. He says, "Don't
link like that in my chat. Animated is okay." So it's not animated.
It's some zoo file that is not animated. It's not a cartoon.
That's crazy. >> It's almost like that's kind of what happens
when your content is talking about this >> through video
games, >> right? Your audience will naturally be curious
and start exploring it
>> especially when you tell them there's nothing wrong.
So, I think this kind of collides with another conservative argument
or like another sort of I don't know how you would describe this
like the incel male, the lonely male argument to use uh that
guy, what was his name? >> They're looking >> when
some dude didn't start really talking to use his thing. >> But
what are you going to say? the isolated male thing. Like I'd
say a lot of people who see this kind of behavior on Twitch,
I I'd say it's like akin to using Twitch and they won't ever
say they have Only Fans, but they will talk about Only Fans or
they will talk about doing kind of that sort of work being workers
on Twitch and they will have links to links, right? They'll have
like indirect ways to get to their >> Yeah. And so like
this is sort of the same thing he's doing on Twitch where he's
like he's not talking about his specifically, but he's he uses
his YouTube and I'm sure on his YouTube he's got a link to his
Twitch channel or something, right? And then on his Twitch channel
he's got like way more DJ conversations going on >> and
that's like that's that's a weird funnel into something. It's
like I get that he's probably being a social attachment to your
star that you shouldn't have >> your star that you get
to sit down and talk to and they they walk you through why it's
okay that you like this freak. >> I just meant Yeah, sure.
Sure, sure. That is with the isolated male thing. When I said
that, I was like saying I was going to say like incelss will
make the argument that like >> oh against >> I think
that's a regular good argument, but I'm saying that like that's
something they will hit the uh like the Twitch thoughts with
all the time, >> Oh, all the time.
as a characteriz
kind of attack would apply to YMS. And I would expect like Doro
and Rob's Media to use that against YMS, especially given this
video now. Seems like his Twitch thing, right? It's like, well,
I don't do this on YouTube, but it's like, well, you link to
your Twitch and then your Twitch you have like these more DJing
conversations. Apparently, I'd be linked in your Twitch chat.
Like it seems like there's a different kind of audience, a different
kind of vibe
>> And it might be that you It's not It's not like that
might be the more suspicious connection is the the links to the
Twitch chat where he has these conversations openly. That's like
the suspicious connection. It's not like the unnamed unlin to
NSFW Twitch Twitter account. I think this is probably a bigger
deal that Nick is laying out. It's like you actually send people
over to this Twitch, they're having like way more DJ conversations.
It's not at all like your YouTube where you do review kids movies.
You do review movies in
>> Right. Like it's not like that. So
>> I'm sorry. I'm going to associate this with somebody.
>> Do you know what this reminds me of? Who this reminds
me of? >> Oh no.
>> A certain cult leader
that Mr. Girl used to have a huge problem with.
>> You have a sex cult.
>> You are on the Bert Simon >> on YouTube. You're
like giving them therapy and then They sign up. They have these
personal calls with you. You help them through their life, through
their problems, and then they sign up for your OAF and now they
also have this tie to >> That's a great argument, by the
way.
>> I do think that's really like very concerning in my
opinion.
>> I think that's very very concerning. The burn [__]
>> but do you agree that Adam is checking off a lot of
those? >> Um, he is. It would depend on how hard he So
Britney that is like an explicit part of her like funnel. >> The
reason that I'm going to say I'm sorry I'm cutting you off. The
reason I'm going to say is because we saw the recent Adam stream.
He doesn't have a huge Twitch stream. He doesn't It's a small
stream. You type in his chat, he's going to see it. He's going
to talk to you. That is you are having direct communication with
him. >> Yep. I think Adam So yes, you are. But I I was
going to say that I think with Britney, the thing that grosses
me out about Britney is she's explicitly doing that and her thing
is like targeting more vulnerable people. Adam is like actually
a curated channel in a way that like he has a talent for breaking
down movies and it's like it's not targeting vulnerable people
other than like I guess if you're on YouTube. >> What do
you mean it's not targeting vulnerable people? You do. I don't
know who YMS is because I'm not a I'm not on the spectrum. I
don't want to see someone hyperanalyze
The Lion King or any other movie for that regard. >> If
you are watching this guy's YouTube videos and then you end up
watching him play video games on Twitch,
>> you've curated you're you've curated for a pretty vulnerable,
antisocial,
>> isolated individual. >> Way less likely, like
a hundred or a thousand times less likely than Britney's. Britney's
is like set up in a very specific way that I >> I think
for Britney just criticism for >> if you type in her YouTube
stream you're probably a vulnerable person. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yep. >> But yeah, for Adam it's at least removed um by
one platform. >> But there is there is still Yeah. But
no no no I I think there is that exact thing. It's just like
to a lesser and I think the differentiation between the >> Wendy
Trump donated $3
PSA. I have signed an executive order permitting chat to post
zoo intimacy in JSD. That's not true. No, you need to for your
>> I am not I'm >> You will be perma banned. >> I
am just a woman. Okay.
>> The things that you guys are confusing for autism, that's
just that's me and my feminine energy.
>> You wouldn't get it.
>> Okay, now that you're here, I need to be right back.
Give me two seconds. I >> think so. I don't know if what
you posted was legit or not, but I'm just saying no actual animal
in my chat, please. I don't I don't want that. >> His first
objection to what he perceives is animal being linked to his
chat is on the basis of legality, not morality, and then he okayed
people posting what he calls animated animal. Now, that doesn't
mean that he doesn't morally object to legit animal. But if you
have a history of enabling this kind of culture in your chat,
especially on a site like Twitch, which is 13 plus, you probably
shouldn't jump into unhinged
allegations. And yes, in that comment, I say this is grooming
behavior. And I call him out in all caps. And I, you know, I
do a little skitso,
right? I was mad because I was typing this as I was at TIFF in
between,
excuse me, running around watching four movies a day. I don't
think that Rob's showing Adam's NSFW Twitter name. >> Oh,
I didn't have that that window highlighted, but there is the
actual explicit thing that confirms for me that he did accuse
them of grooming behavior. So, I didn't see it explicitly, but
now Adam confirms that he did accuse them of grooming behavior,
right? And so, I think probably whatever grooming behavior he's
accusing them of, there's probably nearly an equal argument going
back in his direction that he's engaged in some grooming behavior.
And so if that's our bar for grooming behavior, I don't know
if anybody involved here is coming out clean necessarily, you
know? So I I I think it's a little weird. Aim is funneling kids
to adult content in any meaningful way. I'm saying that as someone
who knows what it looks like when a YouTuber is profiting from
exposing masses of miners to and has been getting away with it
for years. PewDiePie, the face of YouTube in 2015.
>> You guys see the Nuttaku misdirect? Okay, if you know
anything about Nikandros, that was that was 100%. I'm like, Nucks,
Nucks, Nucks, Nucks, it's Nucks, it's >> been away with
it for years >> like that. And then he flashes N up here
and then he goes in a totally different >> PewDiePie, the
face of YouTube. In 2015, he made a video reacting to a child
cartoon because it was a popular meme on 4chan, an 18 plus website.
He has a massive young and impressionable audience, and he still
decided to show them this adult material. Am I watching child
for YouTube? Is this where we are right now? Cuz it looks like
it. >> The video isn't age restricted. And if you look
at the comments, your worst fears are confirmed. How many of
you are under 13? >> Oh, no.
They're Look at that. Look how old he >> He's like 12.
How is this okay? >> This video has 14 million views. PewDiePie
easily made $100,000
off of this video while exposing millions of children to adult
content that could normalize adult shard relationships with them.
It continues to receive comments from children to this very day
who request instructions on how to find the material and then
they report back being disturbed and shocked after seeing it.
>> Hello. Uh,
today I'm playing. They are publishing these comments for any
internet predator in the world to see, telling them that they
are a child who's been exposed to adult material. Some might
say it's the parents responsibility to make sure their kids don't
see this stuff. But this is a 13 plus website. One of the kids
literally >> I would say it's incumbent on you to respect
and understand the toss of the website as well as a creator.
There should be like a double-sided responsibility here. Uh the
creators should have a responsibility to protect the kids and
the parents. There's no reason you can't do it on both sides.
And you know, won't somebody please them to the children? >> The
creator, the platform, and the >> Sure. Three-sided. Sure.
The platform probably just has the the requirement to create
the rules, right? >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Reports, having
watched it in a school computer lab. How is a parent supposed
to stop that? I'm not judging PewDiePie using modern standards
here. There were plenty of people in his comments from the start
saying he's exposing kids to this stuff and requesting for the
video to get age restricted. However, those police fell on deaf
ears. For some reason, the media didn't care about this either.
It's not like he set the end. Now, that's a real story. Do I
think it would be legitimate to call PewDiePie a and a child
groomer for this? No. I still think that this is gross neglect.
What about Adam, though? He's left in a pretty unenviable situation.
He's a furry who enjoys explicit illustrations of animals. And
>> oh, Hamster with a thousand kicks. Thank you very much,
Hamster. Appreciate it. That's like 10 bucks. Let's go. Thank
you. Thank you. >> He's been obsessed with debating the
morality of for over 10 years now. It's revealed that he totally
lied to his audience about never having supported.
Not only was he a supporter of he believed he was on the right
side of history and that it would be normalized in 10 years,
>> 20 years. >> After already having been caught
lying about his position, he has to convince everyone he doesn't
still secretly support. He also needs people to believe him when
he says that his attraction to explicit illustrations of animals
has no connection with being a
>> moral is saying this is a good video. I think it was
a good video too. >> I thought it was really good. Where
is he in the chat? Where's Morau talking? >> Yeah, moral
just said it. Morow real YT.
Moral really white in the chat. Okay. Moral really white. >> Oh,
okay. >> Guys, click on that. Click on that avatar. Okay.
Moral really white. And go to his uh kick channel and follow
him. Okay. Ralph really white. >> I don't believe you.
He's probably >> Uh I like the video, too. I'm I'm thinking
uh Nandros, this is a good decision. I think it is in line with
his channel, the content he normally does. I don't think he had
to go out of his way. And I think there's a very good chance
he gets a boost from a lot of commentary people referencing this
video. He's very smart in multiple dimensions. Okay. Don't mess
with this Finnish guy.
He's a smart cookie. Okay.
>> That's Finland. >> Finland. Yes. He loves sunning.
>> Is that by the Netherlands?
>> Uh, north. It's besides Sweden.
>> Yeah. Yep. And Russia technically. He loves He loves
Tusana. That's every Finnish person ever. There's literally if
you know a Finnish person and you ask them to sauna with you,
okay, they'll be friends forever. If you're not
sit in the sauna. >> Yeah. They love sitting in the sauna.
>> That sounds really gay. >> Yeah, they uh probably.
Yeah.
I have a I have like three Finnish friends here and two of them
built their own saunas.
>> Yeah. You need to build the sauna like every day. >> The
sauna with them. >> You like need to be able to sauna every
day if you're Finnish. >> Every day. >> Especially
in the winter. Yeah. 100%.
>> There are more saunas than people in Finland, which
is crazy. Yeah. Like people have their Everybody has their own
sauna at home. >> Yes. You need to be able to sauna. This
is like critical to their culture.
Everybody has like a smell when they sweat. So there are probably
like a lot of people in the world you don't want to share a sauna
with. >> Yeah. But saunas are especially if they're woodfired
saunas, you usually burn wood chips that have specific smells.
You'll burn like cedar and stuff and it will have like a specific
like smell to the sauna. Like it's that it's that earthy wood
smell. >> So I won't smell sweaty men. >> Yeah. You
won't smell sweaty men. That's not what a sauna smells like.
It smells different. It doesn't smell like um it doesn't smell
like amazing if you don't like the >> saunas in gym smell
like chlorine and old man sweat. >> Yeah. No, it doesn't.
It smells different. Usually es if especially if they're like
wood burning saunas, they'll they'll smell better for sure.
>> attracted to real animals. At least he didn't claim
to be a zoo file in that old stream. That's already something.
But being willing to admit you're pro- zuilia is one level of
crazy. Being willing to admit you're a zoo file is another. There
is one way in which Adam can potentially demonstrate he has actually
changed his mind and that he's not hiding his power level. People
have been calling for Rob to debate Adam on beastiality, but
I think Adam should debate his past self instead. Debate yourself
now. So, I think that's a good point is like uh I I thought this
was silly at first. I was like, "Oh, this is kind of like a weird
thing to say." But I think this is actually good. If if Adam
watched this video and just like commented on how his opinions
have changed, I think that would be helpful. You could you couldn't
still know that he hasn't like changed his opinions now, but
I think he should be able I he hasn't changed a lot of the opinions
because he still made the same argument about possibly like consensual
file
>> If Adam responded to Rob's media, he should respond
to Nick Andros basically,
>> Maybe Rob's media's video got 100,000 views and people
still accused him of stri ending it. This one's only got 1,8006
hours. I believe it can take off, but um it's only got 1,8006
hours, so we'll see if this one takes off more. I can't see it
not taking off and hitting a little more likability or hitting
like a another like bounce in the algorithm, but yeah, I can't
see it. Anyway,
>> break out the studies and the >> Oh, sorry. All
that to say, if it doesn't get over like 10,000 views, I think
Adam just ignores it because he can't deal with criticism from
small channels. if he if he was gonna talk to every small channel
who's criticizing him, I think he'd like run out of time, right?
He he probably has to ignore certain like levels before it gets
to a point. Although, he's never done that before. So, >> really?
Okay. >> I think so. I think if you're like a big creator
and you're getting criticism over something not related to your
primary channel, like it's the more economical decision to just
avoid it. >> But he he made it seem like he really wants
to talk about this. He wants to set it straight. >> So,
it doesn't make sense if he wouldn't engage with Nick Andros.
Um, yeah. I don't know if it I I feel like it would be fine for
him to engage with Nandros. I think he should, but like I just
don't expect him to overall.
Um, and Nandros Neandros is really only accusing him of
how do I put this?
I think Adam could talk about the video. He could review the
video or he could talk to Nicandros directly. Either one would
be good for
>> Yeah. Uh, and apparently we're going to see Neandros
Nicandros's video incorporated into Rob's response when Rob does
do his response.
>> like Nandros has been talking to him a little bit. >> Oh,
Oompy Slaughter, thank you for the uh the the 100 kicks. Full
send. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you. >> Citations and
walk us step by step on how you arrived at your current position
from this past one. That's all I have to say about Adam. So,
where is my big video? It was supposed to come out on the 11th,
but now it's almost October. I'd like to apologize for causing
a disappointment. Announcing that date was really stupid because
I was nowhere near finished and my estimates were completely
off. You might question >> this is an update on the Mudahar,
the big Mudahar video he's doing. >> You guys don't remember
Nicandros made a little preview from his Mudahar research. Made
a little preview that got 167,000 views. Was massive on his channel.
Okay.
Massive video. Huge. Oh, wait, wait, wait. Sorry, sorry, sorry.
It was the 700,000 view video. Nearly 700,000 views for this
Mudahar is being a fake engineer for 10 years. That was like
a video he broke out of his primary video. >> Extra [__]
that wasn't going to fit what was supposed to take down Mudahar.
>> He was leaving. Yeah. So, we all laugh that like he
basically seemingly took Mudahar down in some ways with like
his appetizer. He didn't even get to the full video. That was
a month ago. Yeah, time flies, man. But it was like May. It's
probably just about two months ago. I do think it was July and
not August. July 27th, not uh so it's almost it's like a day
away from being 2 months ago. Man, my my grip on time is great.
>> Anyway, let's uh let's continue. Let's finish this video
and then we'll we'll have a couple comments and then I think
we're ready to get into some of the politics stuff. >> Takes
so long for me to make this video about the secret feud that
caused Mutahar's postnux clarity, especially given how basic
the editing in this video is. The answer is pretty simple. I'm
putting a lot more effort into that video than I did in this
one. I'm aiming to cause maximum impact and I'll be leaving you
with a teaser, which I hope demonstrates that I am doing something.
>> I love that. I love that he's like, I'm going to leave
you with something that shows that I'm putting more effort into
this. Like, oh, this is funny. Hold on. We Let's it. >> Sorry
if you didn't if you didn't see it, Cherry. >> I am doing
something. Let's watch again. >> I'm going to I'm going
to laugh about
in a dream.
>> I didn't know it was specifically Mudahar versus Chud.
>> Oh, well that is probably an opening to a to a section
of his video where I think people called Chud a snake for how
he dealt with Mudahar, right? >> Even though he's like
totally correct. >> Like people were calling Chud a snake.
>> No. No. If he was a snake, then Mudahar would have been
able to charm him. >> Okay. Indians can he would just pull
out his flute. >> Brutal.
Uh, okay. I I love that. That's funny. Okay. But I'm trying to
I'm trying to chill on that. Okay. I'm trying to I'm trying to
chill. But I just wanted to say it's funny that he's like what
everybody likes the NARS videos for is their like deep research.
They're very well argued. It's not I don't even think the editing
like super matters. And he's like here's the reason why I haven't
been able to release this yet, guys. I'm doing I'm doing sick
After Effects edits that nobody cares about or wants. And it
it is funny, but it's also like that's not how do I put this?
That's way better than I could do, but that's not even like good
After Effects work. It's like above average. He might just really
enjoy learning it, but I'm just laughing that like >> Nick
Aronos, if you're watching, I'm sold and I can tell how hard
you're working. Don't let this guy listen. >> I appreciate
how hard he's working, but he's like Michael Jordan playing baseball
by doing After Effects stuff like that. Okay, it's funny. It's
cool, but it's like, well, are you really doing what you're best
at, or are you really giving all you can to the world right now?
I think you have a specific talent at doing some stuff here,
and you're doing the things that aren't that talent, but maybe
it just makes him enjoy it more, and maybe he'll get way >> Do
something with a snake charmer. >> Maybe he'll incorporate
that. Okay,
>> that's [__] up. That's beyond Okay. All
right. And on that note, we're finished with the YMS stuff for
today. Uh, I'm probably just going to end the